Carmen Lopez can only imagine what the
sea looks like but that hasn't stopped
the 21 year old Spaniard from riding the
surf
I feel free and relaxed I don't have any
concerns and it's just me and the wave
coach Lucas Garcia guides Carmen with
whistled signals he's trained her to
compete at the world adaptive surfing
championship no one had ever thought
that blind people could surf and
suddenly we find Carmen who can she
needs some extra help in the water
compared to other adapted sports but at
the end when someone wants something
they can break the limits and everyone
can surf carmen was born with congenital
glaucoma and lost her vision when she
was a child she wants to encourage
others with physical challenges to push
past their limits to keep showing day by
day and with everything that I do if you
want something you can get it whether or
not you have a disability the important
thing is to do what you like the most
people put their own barriers up no one
else puts them there Carmen has also
learned figure skating and horseback
riding with her bold attitude this sees
the limit
you